die zahlen von null bis 20
[Musik]
die aktion beginnt
die lektion beginnt
guten morgen guten tag herr studie
guten morgen
guten tag herr studer
wir lernen heute die zahlen von null bis
los geht's
neu
wie hier
drei tage sehen
sie lief sehen
[Musik]
9 17
sein sieg
gut und jetzt nochmals alles
nacheinander
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20
jetzt losgeht
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20
bravo
wir machen nach der pause einen test
ja
mir einen test
ring ring hause
hast du das fußballspiel gestern gesehen
[Musik]
nein wie war das ergebnis
nein wie wahr
ergebnis
zur halbzeit stand es 0 2
zur halbzeit stand
zu 2
am schluss gewann
eine mannschaft mit 4 zu 2
am schluss gewann ab
meine mannschaft mit 4 zu 2
der ti ist lecker
ich mag ihn
ich mag
die nicht
was magst du
was magst du ich mag kaffee
ich mag kaffee
magst du café magst du café
ja ich mag caffi auch
gehen wir zusammen einen kaffee trinken
ja gerne wann
hast du am freitag um 17 uhr zeigt
hast du am freitag um 17 uhr zeit
nein am freitag habe ich keine zeit
ruf mich am samstag an
wie ist deine telefonnummer
0 7415 23 86
bitte noch einmal und langsam
neu
also 0 7415 2386 richtig
ja genau ja genau
12 papagei 34 großes bier 56 alte heck
78 peter lacht 19 auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
die prüfung beginnt
welche zahl ist das
9 ist richtig
zwölf ist richtig
welche zahl ist das
peter
ich weiß das nicht
ich weiß es nicht
du weißt es nicht
rate mal
3 10 13
13 ist richtig
ist richtig
gut geraten peter
alle haben die prüfer
alle haben die prüfung durch
gratulation gratulation www.hannover.de
ch
[Musik]
dann bist du mutig nachrücker hier
möchtest du weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere und liken dankeschön
[Musik]
auf wiedersehen